vengo a hacerles unas preguntas algunos
de ustedes ha pensado cómo está
envejeciendo
alguno de ustedes ha pensado cómo
quieren vivir su vejez
qué rico oír esas respuestas me alegra
muchísimo algunos de ustedes ha pensado
cómo quiere morir
y bueno vengo a hacerles una invitación
y vengo con coraje entendido cómo actuar
desde el corazón
para poner sobre la mesa un tema tabú mi
tema no es tan taquilleros hay otros más
taquilleros pero vengo a hablarles de
envejecimiento vejez
dependencia pero también vengo a
hablarles de vigor o de vigor de vivir
la vida al final con toda la energía
posible con toda la energía que existe
porque hablar de envejecimiento a
alguien se le ocurre porque es
importante hablar de envejecimiento
porque es la vida y porque estamos en un
mundo que está envejeciendo es una
realidad es inevitable el envejecimiento
y las estadísticas no lo confirman en el
mundo para el 2015 12.3 por ciento de
las personas eran mayores de 60 años se
estima que para el de 2020 esto suba al
13.5 por ciento y para el 2050 se espera
que el 21 por ciento de toda la
población sea vieja sea sean personas
mayores de 60 años que pasa el proceso
de envejecimiento poblacional es
diferente en los diferentes países los
países más envejecidos son los países
desarrollados o con altos ingresos como
por ejemplo cual francia saben cuánto
tardó este proceso de envejecimiento en
francia
100 años miremos cifras en el 2015 el 23
por ciento de la población era mayor de
60 años esta cifra aumentó en el 2020 al
25 por ciento hoy francia ya está
envejecida toda su población ya está
envejecida y en el 2050 el 32.9 por
ciento la población va a ser mayor de 60
años qué pasa en colombia hablemos de
colombia en colombia para el 2010 el 10%
de la población era mayor de 60 años esa
cifra para el 2020 ya va a estar en el
13 por ciento ya vienen que va a pasar
para el 2050 se va a duplicar y un poco
más el 26 por ciento de la población
colombiana va a ser mayor de 60 años
será importante hablar de este tema y
poner este tema sobre la mesa yo creo
que sí a veces con estos y otros temas
nos queremos hacer los de las casas o
queremos tapar el sol con las manos y
hacernos lo que esto no es conmigo los
que envejecen son los de al lado
y el envejecimiento es un proceso que
empieza desde que nacemos estamos
envejeciendo desde el día cero y es un
proceso que nos lleva a la etapa final
de la vida del ciclo de vida que es la
vejez pero esto está encuadrado en el
curso de vida y en el curso de vida y
influyen muchos aspectos que veremos en
un rato y qué opciones tenemos antes
tenemos el camino a o el camino y el
camino a es aceptar nuestro proceso de
envejecimiento asumirlo y actuar en
cambio el camino ve que también es
válido
pero tiene sus consecuencias está en
rechazar todo lo relacionado con
envejecimiento y vejez negarlo y
paralizarnos cuando uno no acepta lo que
está pasando para cuando uno no es
consciente de lo que está pasando se
paraliza y eso tiene sus consecuencias
porque el envejecimiento tiene es tan
importante porque tiene unas
características
lo primero es individual en el proceso
envejecimiento de maria lucia samudio es
diferente al de cada uno de ustedes es
diferente a mariana la hija de mi primo
que nació y tiene tres meses o la de
laura la hija de mi primo que tiene 18
años 13 años o es diferente a el menor
de mis primos que tiene 30 el mío que
tengo 39 o así para arriba hasta llegar
a micro mayor que tiene 78 años
es heterogéneo qué quiere decir eso que
es muy diferente no todos envejecemos
igual no todos llegamos viejos igual a
la vejez en esa época de la vida él es
heterogéneo ya lo vamos a ver más
adelante con un ejemplo de vida es
complejo y entiendan complejos no como
difícil como complicado sino que está
compuesto de muchas partes que lo hace
complejo y además y es lo mejor y es lo
que quiero que se lleven ustedes hoy en
sus mentes y en sus corazones es que es
modificable porque es modificable ya les
voy a contar por ahora hablemos del
envejecimiento de las cosas que tal vez
es un poquito más fácil levante la mano
el que no tiene su celular con con usted
en ese momento
todos bueno muy bien acuérdense de ese
celular que tuve tienen en la mano y el
día 0 que lo compraron se acuerdan era
lo máximo uno tenía la goma y quería
saber cómo funcionaba que cosas nuevas
tenía que gadgets tenía comparado con el
anterior cierto pero el tiempo pasa y el
celular se va desgastando se va dañando
y más si se están si lo están pillan con
contra el piso una que otra vez como
pasa con el mío y me toca cambiarlo
antes de tiempo cierto y qué pasa
salen nueva tecnología isabelle nuevos
celulares y entonces queremos relegamos
ese celular y sale uno nuevo cuál es la
ventaja con el ser humano que nosotros
tenemos podemos tomar la decisión de
relegar nos como adultos como cuando
cuando estamos envejeciendo o de ser
activos en nuestro proceso de
envejecimiento y les traigo una buena
noticia el proceso de envejecimiento y
vejez en un 10% depende de lo genético
pero en cambio en un 90% depende de mi
estilo de vida
depende del estilo de vida
de cada uno y de los que nos rodean
todos podemos ser promotores de un
estilo de vida saludable y de un estilo
de vida pero en envejecimiento activo
para nosotros mismos y para los que nos
rodean porque eso es así porque el
envejecimiento depende de varios
factores está el biológico está el
físico que ahí está el 10% de lo
genético aunque no exclusivamente
también como comemos el ejercicio que
hacemos todas esas actividades van a
influenciar en lo biológico está lo
psicológico la mente nuestro mejor o
peor aliado está lo social está lo
económico lo cultural y muchos más
aspectos esto es lo que hace la ciencia
de la gerontología el estudio del
envejecimiento y dentro de esos está la
geriatría que somos los médicos que nos
dedicamos al cuidado del adulto mayor
les voy a hablar desde mi propia
historia no puedo hablar de abejas
porque todavía no soy vieja
a qué edad como creen ustedes que se
considera una persona vieja alguien sabe
60 años muy bien
lamento decirles la o ms dice que la
persona adulta mayor un envejecimiento
es desde los 60 años y acá venimos a
aceptar bueno entonces va a contar de mi
proceso de envejecimiento a mis 15 años
empezó yo no lo hice consciente en ese
momento estaba bajando en la finca
trotando que que me gustaba mucho en esa
época y alguien ha sentido la la rodilla
débil como que se le va como que se le
tambalea pues la mía tiene una cosa que
se llama desviación patelofemoral es
decir que el fémur y la rodilla están
desalineados y rosa todo el tiempo y
entonces hace que mi rodilla sea una
gelatina y me caí y me caí en un momento
no tan chévere estaba en octavo grado
iba para la excursión del colegio al
parque los nevados la mejor de todas la
que con toda la ilusión uno esperaba y
que paso no pude ir
pasaron varios años y yo seguí con mi
rodilla con medel desviación
patelofemoral nombre tan elegante y
seguí y nunca puse atención nunca para
el médico y hace muy poquito este año mi
rodilla bueno siempre sentía como una
sensación de pesadez como de que tengo
un dolor ahí pero en específico pero
nunca le puse atención el golpe en la
rodilla mezcla que agua y yo me hacía la
de las capas cortas y el año para él ese
nuestro pasado estaba en clase y un día
mi rodilla izquierda dijo no más la que
me molestaba al principio era a la
derecha pues había sobrecargado tanto la
izquierda que la derecha que la
izquierda se afectó y entonces me tocó
ir a urgencias me pusieron analgésico le
dieron una incapacidad que adivinen que
no me la tomé
y fui donde mi ortopedista de siempre
que ya me había mandado varias veces a
terapia yo me hacía la que no quería
varias taxi resonancias que tampoco me
las quería hacer y me tocó finalmente a
servir y me dio el diagnóstico de una
artrosis temprana sí señores a mis 39
años tengo una artrosis temprana y les
voy a contar tiene muchos efectos y el
proceso de aceptación ha sido normal
pero les voy a contar lo que más me ha
molestado yo antes me tapara en un solo
tiempo ahora la fuerza en mis músculos
no me lo permite y me toca pararme en
varios tiempos ha sido lo que más me ha
molestado pero bueno ahí vamos y
entonces yo con este 10% de genética que
hizo que tenga una artrosis temprana
pues voy a tener un envejecimiento de
alguna forma pero eso lo miraremos en el
futuro por ahora en el hoy y que les
quiero contar que no todos llegamos
igual a la vejez hay diferentes formas
de vivir la vejez hay personas viejas
vigorosas y aquí quiero traer a colación
a mi tío carlos que a sus 78 años
trabaja en proyectos en la sierra nevada
de santa marta trabajando por la
agricultura orgánica y se va en bus y
hace un resto de cosas y es totalmente
activo
también hay personas frágiles y son esas
personas que por el efecto acumulativo
de la edad tienen una situación más
vulnerable se casan más rápido pierden
peso pierden fuerza pero también hay
personas con diferentes grados de
dependencia y ya están más afectadas se
los voy a compartir con la historia de
vida de mis abuelos mis abuelos duraron
más o menos sesenta y pico años casados
y yo tuve la fortuna de tener unos
abuelos vigorosos me acuerdo que hoy
íbamos todos los domingos a la casa yo
me encontraba en el club con mi abuelo
jugando tenis jugando y jugando tenis
ambos jugaban bridge pasábamos las
navidades salíamos de paseo y eran
personas activas en el 2005 más o menos
a mi abuelo le diagnosticaron un cáncer
de próstata y ahí entró en etapa de
fragilidad ya no tenía las mismas
fuerzas ya no pudiera jugar tenis pero
seguía viviendo su vida
de alguna forma y fueron avanzando las
cosas y empezó a tener a presentar
cambios de memoria se le olvidaban las
cosas las perdía la red un día empezó a
tener problemas para manejar el dinero
hicieron el diagnóstico de alzheimer si
de alzheimer esa enfermedad que afecta
al zinc entre el 5 y el 8 por ciento de
la población esta enfermedad que se
diagnostica un caso cada 4 segundos
y fue un proceso complejo y requirió de
la unidad de toda la familia mi abuelo
se fue deteriorando inicialmente
presentada dependencia leve después
dependencia moderada hasta que presentó
dependencia severa y fue necesario
contratar a un tercero para que nos
ayudara a cuidar toda la familia
estábamos ahí eso fue complejo no fue
fácil hubo momentos muy difíciles pero
el reflejo de cómo fue su envejecimiento
se notó al final de su vida
afortunadamente siempre fue un excelente
deportista y evitamos que tuviera tantas
contracturas y tantas posiciones que se
presentan en las personas que ya quedan
inflamadas pero también era una persona
de un temperamento fuertísimo y en las
crisis de cambio de comportamiento éstos
eso también se veía
murió mi abuelo y mi abuela a los 2 años
le detectaron una demencia vascular con
ella el proceso fue más fue diferente
ella decidió cuando tenía una demencia
leve institucional a institucionalizarse
es decir irse a vivir a un lugar donde
donde la cuidaban a pesar de que le
ofrecimos que viviera con nosotros no lo
quiso hacer y se le respetó su autonomía
y con ella fue muy fuerte y para mí
personalmente el proceso de aceptación
fue complicado no lo podía aceptar hasta
el punto que al final mi abuela en vez
de lavarse los dientes no se quería
lavar los dientes y mucho en los últimos
seis meses nunca solo una voz y yo no lo
aceptaba yo iba con la crema los
pacientes con demencia aprenden por
imitación no me lavan los dientes y ella
no lo lograba yo le da la crema y ella
se levantaba fue difícil pero también es
una forma de envejecer que cambió que
toda la familia estuvimos ahí para
acompañarlo con esto tengo muchos
aprendizajes muchos aprendizajes de vida
a nivel personal y teniendo en cuenta lo
que
se ha descubierto en las zonas azules
que son los cuatro países donde viven
las personas más longevas más activas y
más saludables que son en italia en
costa rica en loma linda califórnia y en
okinawa les vengo a compartir que estoy
haciendo yo hoy de eso una de las
primeras cosas es la espiritualidad mi
confianza en dios es innegable y eso es
la inspiración para levantarme todos los
días y cumplir con mi misión de vida y
con lo que más me apasiona cuidar y
acompañar a las personas mayores desde
mi trabajo también me apoyó en la
biodanza un estilo de vida que me ayuda
muchísimo la otra cosa importantísima
que se encontró en ese estudio
transcultural es el poder de la familia
y lo vi reflejado en mis abuelos cuando
con la unión entre todos pudimos
cuidarlos y acompañarlos en una etapa y
en un momento muy difícil
lo otro es el poder de los amigos y aquí
las amigas con las cuales no pude ir han
optado todavía están ahí no sé si es
porque nos estamos acercando a los 40 y
tenemos un chat que se dice calentando
motores para los 40 para poder organizar
nuestra celebración pero
muy lindo el reencuentro y a nivel
profesional en dos áreas desde que
acompañé a mis dos abuelos entendí que
yo tenía que ejercer la medicina de otra
manera y que me tenía que dedicar a
hacer procesos de acompañamiento para
las personas mayores con un programa de
atención integral para el adulto mayor
para que con un solo objetivo darle vida
a los días de esa persona no importa si
es una persona vigorosa
frágil con cualquier grado de
dependencia o si está en final de vida y
finalmente en la universidad como
profesora invito al resto de los
profesores a que incluyan dentro de sus
materias dentro de la educación el todo
lo que se pueda presentar desde las
diferentes profesiones para atender las
necesidades de los adultos mayores que
son muchas muy diversas y muy complejas
yo desde medicina ya lo estoy esperando
empezando a hacer y espero que los
médicos del futuro que son los que me
van a atender a mí ya muchos de ustedes
tengan la capacidad de atendernos de una
manera diferente que están haciendo
ustedes por su envejecimiento los invito
a que lo consulten esta noche con la
almohada que están haciendo ustedes para
acompañar la vejez de sus cds seres
queridos también los invito a que lo
consulten con la almohada yo acepto que
envejecer es vivir
envejecer es vivir e inevitable vivo el
presente el hoy el aquí y el ahora y
cada paso lo doy con la intención de
construir el pasado tiene un futuro
quiero ver gracias los abrazos con mi
corazón